[Brotherhood 2.0 theme]
[BANG]
Good morning John, it's Wednesday, September 5th.
[Guitar]
[Singing] Oh, Hello evil lady at the grocery store.
It seems that you don't know what the express lane is for.
It says "12 items or less" but you're exempt from that I guess,
and you've started up an argument about coupons.
Oh, don't make me kill you over 25 cents.
I'll give you a freaking quarter if it makes that much difference.
And you just remembered something you forgot to get,
and your husband will be right back with it.
Okay. That's it. I'm gonna kill you.
Yeah, I'm gonna kill you and possibly your whole family, too.
All I want is some courtesy, kindness, and maybe an apology.
If you don't get out of my grocery line
I'll do scorpion's fatality and rip out your spine.
I'm usually a very peaceful person but I'm gonna kill you.
I just wrote a note to the guy down the street
who recently invested in a giant SUV.
It said "I hope you know that we're fighting a war
so you can get your fat ass home from the grocery store.
You better trade it in or I'm gonna kill you."
Yeah, I'm gonna kill you with a car bomb in your H2.
I don't think it'd be too much to ask for you to be a bit less of an ass.
I suggest you reinvest in a Honda Fit.
If you don't, you're gonna regret it.
I'm usually a very peaceful person, but I'm gonna kill you.
[Guitar]
It's 3 AM and my neighbour upstairs
is actually worse than my worst nightmares.
They had some friends over for some late night Red Rover,
and now... yeah... they're practicing tap dance.
[guitar]
Yeah, I'm gonna kill you, and all your loud-ass friends, too.
I don't think it'd be too much to ask
for you to be a bit less of an ass.
If I don't get some peace and quiet,
I'll put you on a strychnine diet.
I'm usually a very peaceful person,
but I'm gonna kill you.
[guitar]
I'm really not an angry person.
But people just get on my nerves sometimes.
Thanks to Katherine for all of the help with that song,
particularly with coming up with the idea for it,
and several of the lines.
So, if you want more than that, I'm afraid I can't give it to you
because singing like that has made my voice a little bit weak.
I am not a bass. I have to work for it, and it tears it up in there.
My neck vein coming up, neck vein neck veeeeiinnn.
Anyway, I gotta go. See you tomorrow.